vorrei portarvi con me in un piccolo
viaggio in quello che ritengo essere
forse per autoreferenzialità il più
essenziale dei progetti in questa
bellissima giornata e cioè quel progetto
che riguarda l'attraversamento delle
nostre menti per cercare di capire quali
sono i vincoli e quali sono le
possibilità con cui ci misuriamo quando
dobbiamo cambiare idea e mi pare proprio
che alla luce delle cose che abbiamo
sentito fino a qui
noi siamo nella condizione di dover
cambiare idea non è la migliore delle
condizioni per noi esseri umani perché
voi sapete che c'è un rapporto molto
stretto fra la nostra capacità creativa
e gli stati ansiogeni e l'anzhi è un
grande distruttore di energia
di conseguenza per certi aspetti
potremmo dire che abbiamo aspettato
troppo per altri aspetti possiamo dire
che abbiamo delle buone possibilità e
allora questa mia riflessione si
svolgerà tra quelle che vi proporrò come
delle cattive notizie e quelle che
cercherò di proporvi come delle buone
notizie con cui concluderò siamo di
fronte ad una svolta radicale e tutte le
volte che noi siamo di fronte ad una
svolta radicale dobbiamo fare i conti
con il nostro mondo interno perché tutto
quello che produciamo all'esterno è
figlio della nostra capacità elaborativa
non è la prima volta che ci troviamo di
fronte a una svolta di questo tipo
quando io avevo 19 anni ho partecipato a
milano alle attività di ricerca di un
gruppo che si chiamava gruppo anti h in
cui c'erano dei grandi professori che mi
hanno insegnato cose importanti e loro
stavano studiando esattamente il
problema dell'auto distruttività umana
nel momento in cui per la prima volta la
specie umana aveva costruito un arma la
bomba atomica che poteva distruggere
interamente la specie è comunque il
sistema vivente sul pianeta terra
per molti aspetti oggi noi rispetto alla
situazione attuale riguardante la
biodiversità siamo in una condizione
analogo
che cosa succede quando dobbiamo
cambiare idea o comunque quando ci
troviamo di fronte a un problema vi
propongo uno dei più semplici
esperimenti costruiti da watson il 66
che attiene alla mia disciplina
se fate con me questo piccolo esercizio
rapidamente chiedendoci qual è la regola
con cui è stata generata la seguente
tripletta di numeri e rispondete
abbastanza immediatamente ognuno di voi
ci sarebbe bello poterlo fare
l'esercizio se avessimo l'occasione poi
di rifletterci non è questa la
situazione però vale lo stesso ognuno di
noi può vedere che le prime tre cifre
svolgono una funzione altamente
vincolante rispetto a quello che
scriveremo dove ci sono i tre puntini
sospensivi vi prego di riflettere
commesso questa semplicissima cosa e
quindi di ricavare insieme a me
alcune delle considerazioni che la della
mia disciplina traggo per cercare di
comprendere che cosa ci accade quando
dobbiamo cambiare idea
vi do un dato molto semplice tutti gli
esperimenti di scienza cognitiva mettono
in evidenza una cosa elementare di
fronte a due possibilità conservare
l'esistente o cambiare noi esseri umani
qualunque sia l'oggetto della scelta e
anche a fronte di una evidente
indesiderabile conseguenza nel momento
in cui conserviamo lo status quo nei due
terzi dei casi scegliamo di conservare
l'esistente la nostra ansia si risolve
nella rassicurazione nella principale
parte dei casi cambiare idea significa
per noi investire in eccedenza tirarci
su per il codino come il barone di
munchausen è bene che cosa accade cosa
facciamo spontaneamente quando dobbiamo
affrontare un cambiamento o quando
dobbiamo affrontare una situazione in
primo luogo cerchiamo ancoraggi nella
storia nel passato il secondo luogo
cerchiamo scorciatoie di pensiero se
possiamo scegliamo la via più semplice
abbiamo una mente economica non nel
senso che siamo risparmiatori ma nel
senso che cerchiamo le soluzioni più
immediate
pratichiamo la path dependence cioè ciò
che abbiamo fatto fino ad ora ciò che
abbiamo fatto fino ad ora in questo caso
un proverbio molto diffuso che conoscete
tutti
contiene una densa teoria scientifica
chi lascia la via vecchia eccetera
eccetera
pratichiamo un meccanismi di auto
rinforzo pur di mantenere la posizione
siamo strenuamente legati a una tendenza
alla conferma queste sono tutte
questioni che richiedono richiedono una
grande attenzione quando di fronte per
esempio agli straordinari progetti che
questa bellissima giornata ci ha offerto
noi usiamo un atteggiamento normativo
bisogna dobbiamo è necessario che va
benissimo è chiaro perché per fortuna
siamo anche la specie è capace di creare
e siamo capaci di praticare l'utopia che
come è noto non è il luogo che non c'è è
il luogo che non c'è ancora e questo è
un punto su cui riflettere con
attenzione ma tanto meglio lo facciamo
se siamo capaci di elaborare le
resistenze e le difese che il
cambiamento ci suscita dentro nelle
nostre menti individuali e collettive
ebbene abbiamo un sistema cognitivo
tendenzialmente conservatore la legge
dei due terzi l'ho già detto prima
produciamo strategie di selezione delle
ipotesi e quindi la supposizione
dell'inedito e meno praticata basta
considerare l'evoluzione del pensiero
scientifico per rendersene conto e meno
praticata dell'ipotesi innovativa
attribuiamo scarsa importanza alle
informazioni falsificante nel senso che
ci siamo a tutti i costi di confermare
quello che finora abbiamo scoperto
quante volte diciamo siamo tutti
d'accordo ma questo non vuol dire che
siamo d'accordo su qualcosa che va bene
facciamo prevalere le rappresentazioni
mentali di eventi coerenti con le nostre
aspettative
ebbene quando applichiamo questo
ragionamento al tema della biodiversità
e al paesaggio
noi facciamo una scoperta che oggi
richiede per esempio un grande
cambiamento abbiamo visto paesaggi
particolarmente belli
prima noi veniamo da una tradizione se
vuoi la studiate la potete trovare
particolarmente presente nel fra un po
vi darò qualche dato particolarmente
presente nell'esperienza delle persone
in cui il paesaggio è ancora concepito
come un decoro e uno sfondo e non come
condizione della vivibilità sul pianeta
terra
l'ipotesi che noi abbiamo formulato su
questo tema è che il paesaggio di venga
invece l'entità che emerge al punto di
connessione fra il nostro mondo interno
il nostro mondo esterno con la
mediazione del principio di
immaginazione non esiste oggi la
possibilità di parlare ancora una volta
in termini dualisti cd naturale e
artificiale abbiamo sentito prima una
magnifica relazione sull'acqua e quindi
su pratiche peraltro tradizionali e
vernacolari che assumono una grande
rilevanza scientifica ma come un prato
di montagna non è in nessun modo
qualcosa di naturale perché tutti sanno
che presto sarebbe mangiato dal bosco e
dai rovi se non fosse mantenuto è fatto
ad arte da noi e non ci rimane che
assumerci la responsabilità di come lo
facciamo ad arte
ebbene perché perché agisce e vado
veloce secondo principio della
termodinamica che porta che cosa porta
alla banale considerazione che la fine
di ogni processo alla qualità
dell'energia dell'energia è sempre
peggiore rispetto all'inizio qui un
grande economista come giorgio score
purtroppo non molto utilizzato dalla
disciplina economica ci ha consegnato
molti anni fa un testamento che merita
di essere ripreso con cura come reagiamo
però tendenzialmente di fronte a questa
trasformazione della vivibilità cioè del
rapporto fra noi e gli ecosistemi di cui
siamo parte o detta in altri termini
come reagiamo di fronte alla svolta
radicale nella quale anche in base a una
lunga storia densa di miti noi finora
siamo stati e tuttora lo siamo convinti
di essere sopra le parti come specie
siamo nella condizione di renderci conto
di essere parte del tutto
come la affrontiamo questa questione
bene una ricerca approfondita che
abbiamo fatto su questo tema che è una
ricerca di campo fatta con campioni di
popolazione in europa mette in evidenza
riportata in quel libro mette in
evidenza che sono tre le sindromi come
le abbiamo chiamate che mettiamo in
campo in prima istanza la prima è la
sindrome dell'after you
perché dovrei cominciare io a usare i
mezzi pubblici fallo prima tu dopo
magari cominciò anch'io
la seconda l'abbiamo chiamata tight enix
syndrome ed è molto più presente nella
ricerca di quello che si potrebbe
immaginare ci sono degli iceberg
potenziali al lungo la rotta della nave
beh insomma lascia perdere è stata il
prossimo la prossima bottiglia di
champagne a e poi si vedrà c'è un
atteggiamento molto diffuso che è quella
che porta a quello che porta a dire ci
penserà chi governa non saremo mica noi
ad occuparci di questo problema
sono tutti ovviamente meccanismi di
difesa e resistenza e rispetto al
cambiare idea
allora le cattive notizie quali sono
quando studiamo il change mons myint che
il tema su cui stiamo lavorando negli
ultimi 15 anni cioè che cosa succede a
noi quando dobbiamo cambiare idea
vediamo prevalere atteggiamenti di
indifferenza di conformismo di
saturazione
non chiudiamo gli occhi su queste cose
cavandocela con delle posizioni
normative che sono euforiche ed
entusiasti che non si cambia senza
elaborarle come dice musi ne l'uomo
senza qualità
se vuoi attraversare una porta stretta
non dimenticare che gli stipiti sono
duri quindi quali sono le buone notizie
quali sono le buone notizie la
principale è che siamo una specie
creativa cioè una specie attenzione a
questa parola potrebbe apparire
scivolosa che cosa intendo qui per
creatività intendo la capacità specie
specifica di noi animali umani dotati di
linguaggio verbale di coscienza
simbolica di comporre e ricomporre in
modo almeno in parte originale i
repertori disponibili oggi abbiamo avuto
una carrellata di indicazioni che
portano in questa direzione
non ultima la creatività artistica che
per tutta questo punto di vista
meriterebbe una grandissima
considerazione se non altro come istanza
di riferimento e metaforica bene siamo
portatori di una caratteristica che
abbiamo studiato a livello neuro
fenomenologico che abbiamo definito
tensione rimpiante cioè una possibilità
costante di estensione del modello neuro
fenomenologico di noi stessi parolone
del modo in cui pensiamo noi stessi e
del modo in cui ci sentiamo dentro la
situazione e quindi siamo capaci di
comporre e ricomporre almeno in parte
originale i repertori di cui disponiamo
questo è quello che siamo ma allora
perché tendono a prevalere le condizioni
precedenti
cercherò di dire questo verso la fine
della mia riflessione per indicare che
cosa per indicare il fatto che educhiamo
molto poco alla creatività ma non
pensiate che io sia qui a proporre l'ora
di creatività nella scuola questo
sarebbe semplicemente tragico ma è
perché abbiamo bisogno di praticare il
conflitto della conoscenza quando
facciamo educazione noi tutti siamo
andati a scuola io insegno in università
ma quante volte quando ci hanno proposto
un certo tipo di geografia ci hanno
proposto un altro punto di vista e
quindi ci hanno insegnato le geografie
io sono allievo di heinz fromm forster
un grandissimo neurobiologo da cui ha
imparato cose fondamentali
hines aveva un figlio di sei anni me lo
raccontava sempre che oggi insegna
matematica princeton e mi ha raccontato
un aneddoto un giorno dicendo guarda
ludwig si chiamava l'ultimo poiché heinz
era figlio di una sorella di viti casa e
mi ha detto lu di liga è tornato a casa
a sei anni in prima elementare piangendo
gli ho detto che cosa è successo mi ha
detto ho preso un brutto voto in
matematica ma com'è possibile sei un
genio di matematica ma dice sala
insegnanti ha chiesto quando fa tre per
due
e io ho risposto alzando subito la mano
tre più tre e m'ha dato un brutto voto
ecco questo è ciò che accade all'interno
dei processi educativi e se tu vuoi la
creatività deve educare alla creatività
non hai un'altra possibilità e questo
non deve accadere solo nella scuola deve
accadere in contesti come
questi in cui si parla del senso del
possibile deve accadere nei contesti
della nostra vita quotidiana deve
accadere nella ricerca
insomma la creatività è una nostra
possibilità se abbiamo voglia di fare i
conti con i vincoli a cambiare
comportamento rispetto alla biodiversità
abbiamo questa via davanti a noi
e l'augurio è che ognuno di noi la
pratichi ascoltando quest'anno
celebriamo un anniversario di alberto
alberti amico come sapete ha detto sì
realista domanda l'impossibile grazie